the joke
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I am Rosanna Lockwood here on uncensored
tonight Lucy letby's Killing Spree was
aided by quote White Privilege that is
the incendiary claim now being made in
the wake of her conviction and we're
going to be debating it disgraced prince
Andrew joins the king at his summer
Retreat as peace talks with Harry are
apparently shelved is Charles reigning
and the Rogue Royals or are they
plotting a comeback
and would you read a thriller written by
a robot crime writer AJ chowdry is using
AI to sex up his stories legendary
author Frederick Forsyth says it's
sacrilege they're both joining us live
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood welcome to appears
morganland center with me Rosanna
Lockwood in the chef appears again this
evening now money
money or lack of it I think that's what
most of us care about the moment I know
it's the one topic I speak about most
with friends family and colleagues
everyone has different circumstances of
course but they're all struggling in
their own way and I know I want to speak
so I'm sat here on television talking to
you but it is a topic I care deeply
about as a journalist so what if I were
to tell you the bosses of ftse 100
companies so that's the sort of biggest
companies in the UK listed publicly
they're now earning 118 times that of
the average British worker after they've
got an average half a million pay rise
last year now this is all according to
this annual study by Think Tank the high
pay center when I tell you that do you
feel surprised do you feel outraged
given what you are dealing with given
the bank of England have actually tried
telling workers to show restraint not
ask for big pay Rises to help control
inflation
or do you think a median 3.9 million
pound a year salary is actually Fair pay
for a highly skilled and high pressured
role think about what we're talking here
we're talking about the bosses of mining
companies Banks supermarkets energy
companies
and some in the business World actually
say we need to be paying those top CEOs
more even more than that even more than
3.9 million pounds of median a year
because this country needs to attract
the best talent and compete
internationally an equivalent boss in
the US is probably going to receive a
salary of around 14 million dollars so
of course they do everything bigger over
there but what we want to talk about is
how well does this serve the average
person we're going to be discussing that
at the top of the show today as well as
the government's handling of Migrant
arrivals now that might seem a strange
combination to you but the issues of
money and immigration are increasingly
linked and could well decide the way
we'll vote in the next election because
if you mention falling living standards
for British people at the moment which
are real I don't need to tell you a lot
about this you know already but people
are losing their homes they're using
food banks businesses are folding people
are struggling to make ends meet if you
mention this some people will use the
conversation to claim that migrants to
this country are receiving better
treatment so you can see how these two
topics have become entwined and this is
especially important for political
parties seeking power one thing seems to
unite voters on both the left and the
right at the moment and that is that
something somewhere along the line has
gone terribly wrong
joining me on tonight's panel to discuss
all this political correspondent Ava
Santina talk TV's Richard Tice and
socialist author Grace Blakely all three
of you thanks so much for coming in and
you know I don't want to jump ahead of
you ladies but I'm going to come to
Richard first unusually quite right
unusually on this because you are I
think you know people call you a city
big wig you've held positions with
enlisted companies before
um but at the same time you can
understand of course that people in this
country really are struggling so what do
you make of this news about the way CEOs
are paid yeah look um in principle I
agree with free markets I believe in
capitalism as a as a fundamental way of
of growing the economy but the reality
is that this has become ever more
disjointed I think it's about 40 years
ago that ratio was about 30 times it's
now 118 so that it it has just gone off
the dial and if you look at the I think
the average increase 16 in the last year
and yet all those uh those very same
bosses have been increasing the the pay
of their own uh their own teams their
own staff buy much less than that you've
got public sector pay Awards in the sort
of five to ten percent Mark and you've
got the government of the bank of
England saying that you had to show pain
restraint well leadership is about
actually leading from the front and I
think they've done themselves and the
private sector and the cause of business
and free markets a great disservice if
you head this way they will say as you
touched on we're in an international
market you've got to pay international
pay rates and it is true in the US the
pay rates are off the down but that
doesn't help ordinary folk really
struggling here in the UK I want to pick
up on that point of you know the idea
that we're all for free markets right
well actually no okay even if you are
free Rockets I think most people
probably say they're probably a good
thing right how could you object to free
markets it's all about freedom and yet
we actually do not live in a society
characterized by free markets at all and
if you look at the ratio between CEO and
worker pay it's much higher in companies
that dominate their market so in like
monopolistic companies and companies
that um are basically able to kind of
enclose a certain market and then
extract from workers from planet and
often from the taxpayer as well and the
reason that you have such high ratios of
CEO pay to work a pay in the US is
because it's an incredibly concentrated
monopolistic economy where prices are
higher on average workers wages are
lower on average and basically
corporations can kind of get away with
doing anything we're moving in that
direction do they have much higher
growth rates which they would say
justify higher right higher pay
unfortunately
growth rate no they do I mean much
higher growth rates which is why you've
got I mean sixty percent of the market
capitalization across the whole world is
concentrated in the US look I want to
bring it over on this and ask whether
you think it's right to conflate the
issue of cop which might seem odd with
the migrant arrivals but money and
migrants that is what the next election
is going to be fought on yeah and maybe
and it's probably a really helpful
comparison if you're say the head of a
company a CEO or you are you know
leading a government into what's going
to be a cultural War election I mean
personally I don't I can't I can't see
the connection I think there's a lot of
rhetoric around how much money's
migrants supposedly get when they enter
this country they actually don't they've
got about probably 35 pounds a week if
they're likely if they're lucky it's a
tiny stipend it's not a reason why
you're across the channel you know you
wouldn't put yourself at risk for that
time lodging three meals a day free
cleaning
I just think this is where the arguments
where it gets overly simplistic because
when you're put onto a barge away into a
hotel these people don't want to be
there they come here because they'd like
to work and they'd like to start a life
here I just think it's overly simplistic
and it's actually just insensitive and
there's a lawful and legal way to do
that 1.1 million people came here
legally lawfully
so most of those people that's half a
million of those that they came from
Hong Kong and then the other half of
many they come from Ukraine and there's
about 40 000 people who came from
Afghanistan and other countries actually
the the number is Tiny so when you're
done is 1.1 million gross lawfully came
into the U.S across the channel when
we're talking about people who they are
they're coming out they're not
ukrainians and they're not coming here
from from they've come here from a safe
country it's sorry for illegal Richard
this debate just becomes so overly
emotive and it's basically it comes down
to kind of good migrant bad migrant did
they come have our illegal did they come
here by via an
illegality actually let's just take a
step back and look at what's actually
causing this problem right the reason
that we've had this big increase in
people coming to this country for from
poor parts of the world is because those
places are increasingly facing factors
like climate breakdown they're facing
conflict often caused by countries like
the UK they're facing social breakdown
poverty these structural factors are
what's pushing people here and they're
not going away and the reason that we
are seeing more people coming into this
country through illegal routes is
because we aren't creating the legal
reasons
those are two routes that we opened the
last year we don't open roots of people
who are coming from Afghanistan are
coming from that you know Saudi Arabia
people from Afghanistan right who were
former translators who helped us tens of
thousands of people since the evacuation
thousands of people uh those two yeah
you've both got differing views in the
data here Richard um you have stated
about the boarding and the lodging and
this is why I think the two issues get
conflated Grace bring you back in on
this then the way the British public
received this you can see sometimes when
people talk about cost of living crisis
I can't afford to pay my bills but
migrants are getting you know and you've
heard the phrases about hotel rooms and
smartphones and whether or not that is
true there are various different bits of
evidence that point towards some support
being provided or not how do we Sim
simplify you we've already got a fight
going on about the amount of data on
migrants that is out there I mean how do
you simplify this in the British
Public's mind I mean it's a red herring
it's the perfect distraction isn't it if
you have people that literally cannot
afford to heat their homes you have
people who are facing homelessness
literally facing being put out onto the
street we have this massive crisis in
families who've literally not been able
to stay in their homes and they are now
living you know in rented accommodation
or sorry in um temporary accommodation
or literally sometimes on the streets
and then you can come in and say oh it's
not the government's fault or it's not
the fact that we have loads and loads of
homes in London that are completely
empty because they're just used for
investment it's actually migrants fault
and these poor people who are literally
living sometimes in most squalid
accommodation with like 10 people to a
room don't blame the government needs to
look after your own people people
you recognize we've got a problem and
you want to compound the problem by
having open borders and letting millions
of people who wants a better life
literally not what I think that's
exactly what that's the influence that's
the exact inference is
I I appreciate it's not three women on
one or Richard here but I do I don't
think that's quite uh Grace saying she's
capable of saying that herself let's
talk about one of the issues then that's
come up in the last few days with
regards to the migrant situation which
is that we in the United Kingdom soon
gave France 480 million pounds uh this
year to try and stop the boats you know
his big phrase coming across less than
half of boats have been stopped so far
this is according to data from the
Telegraph newspaper uh overall though 18
fewer migrants coming across the channel
since last year but we are spending so
much more we only spent for 54 million
pounds sent it to France in 2021 now
sending 480 million pounds how is he
going to justify that over well I mean
it's it's 150 miles of Coastline on
northern France it's incredibly
difficult to police and I mean if you
look at how Australia tried to deal with
it you know quote-unquote crisis that
they were facing I mean they were
sending people over to Papua New Guinea
and that was costing them something like
half a billion US dollars every single
year this action of trying to remove
people or trying to stop people from
moving countries it doesn't work it's
not viable I think
since Australia pushed people back they
pushed the boats back they did with the
processing offshore and guess what they
stopped the boats 10 years ago okay and
it hasn't been a problem
this evening you're wrong
they actually have that they have
exactly the same issues that we have so
there's a lot of people who are stuck in
hotels a lot of people who aren't able
to access visas and they have been
moving people outside off of Australia
off of the you know the Homeland or
whatever for quite some time now since
like 10 years the 2013 general election
in Australia was won by Tony Abbott on a
three-word slogan stop the boat and here
we are and the only reason he stopped
them was because he pushed the boats
back from where they came and that's
exactly the only way that we will stop
the boats pick up and safely take back
which we can do under existing
International treats which kind of
proves the the point I was making right
which is the the fact that okay so Tony
Abbott comes in on this platform to stop
the boat so he perhaps manages to reduce
somewhat the number of boats coming over
incredibly expensive well over 95 and
yet the Australian political discourse
is still dominated by this issue of
immigration why because it's a very
convenient thing for politicians to say
the country isn't you know failing
because of us you're not seeing Rising
inequality falling wages inflation
because of us it's because there are
these people coming over here who want
to simultaneously steal your jobs and
also leech off the public sector
talk about this right now it is
able you know there can be falling
living standards but there can also be a
migration issue that a lot of people are
concerned about the two can exist and a
good government should be able to manage
them both at the same time sure but a
bad government is going to say I'm not
going to do anything on either of these
issues and actually I'm going to turn
these people who are suffering you know
quite substantially into a scapegoat so
that you don't blame us for your
problems we agree go on Richard because
this is a bad government it's failing no
actually because this is a bad
government that is failing pretty much
at everything I mean if you actually say
what are they doing well what's working
the answer is the square root of not a
lot so they're failing on the migrants
issue they're failing on cost of living
controlling costs uh reducing energy
costs they're failing on creating growth
the national debt is uh is increasing
the failing on waiting lists I can't
think of anything that they're doing
well so that on that we probably agree
but that's I think why we're having this
conversation that's why the government
keeps saying you know making this issue
of small votes the biggest political
issue in the country when actually we
are in love this cost of living crisis
if you talk to people outside London let
me tell you
and yet here we are talking about what
is actually in real terms not a massive
problem relatively speaking it's amazing
majority of refugees are actually in
countries
to the British people it is a huge
problem when they see when they see this
not nearly as much
don't talk to some people in some
coasters Hospital waiting room and see
if they care about like small boats they
care about the fact that they literally
cannot get cancer treatment might we
open the problem the program's saying
something has gone very very wrong or we
can't even agree what the biggest issue
in this country is Richard Ava Grace
thank you very much a Punchy start to
the show there now uncensored next
tonight did Lucy let these white
privilege quote unquote stop her from
being cool earlier that's what some are
claiming in the wake of her conviction
will be debating that after the break
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
the
time
Minister President Trump Mr President
for this lady Stormy Daniels Jordan
Peterson welcome to all these people
protesting just don't get it any of them
don't it's not slightly patronizing
when you're going through the treatments
you have some tears God I'm such a softy
I'm not a performing monkey come on
Brian and it's something that really
hurt me because they doubt of my words
a woman is me a woman is somebody whose
breasts hang down to her stomach thought
the marginalized we're supposed to have
the voice I've been a terrible liar
you're being a Karen pass Morgan
kiss condoms the kids caskets will get
you coming and we'll get you going I
think it's only room for one king man
now I'm saying
[Music]
foreign
ER that you can vote for peers in the
Piers Morgan uncensored the National
Television Awards go online have your
say nationaltvawards.com but you can
also scan the code on your screen right
now hold your phone up as though you're
taking a photo scan that code and vote
for peers he's up for a gone for best TV
interview you know he would love to add
to that trophy collection in his
dressing room so do get voting and uh
all party best wishes on to him he'll be
back soon now welcome back to the show
sentencing of serial killer Lucy let be
to a lifetime Behind Bars the judge
yesterday laying out how her horrific
crimes took place over a period of
almost 13 months many are now
questioning why it took so long to bring
letby to Justice one controversial
explanation is race as one detective put
it she was so beige these are quotes and
vanilla that she didn't look like a
serial killer whatever a serial killer
is supposed to look like
the president of the Royal College of
nurses meanwhile has claimed she would
have been stopped sooner letby if she
wasn't white and yesterday glamor
magazine published an article saying
White Privilege helped let B commit
murders in plain sight and she's still
benefiting from it
so is linking race to the failures and
the let the case Justified can we learn
anything from asking this question or is
it just simply divisive joining me to
debate this the author and journalist
Jenny kleeman in the studio and the
former chair of the Institute of
equality and diversity practitioners
Linda Bellos joining us down the line
Linda as you're there thank you for
joining us I'll start with you and say
is this a legitimate complaint that
letby was overlooked because she was
white
I'm not sure in part in party it is
right but I would suggest that social
class was also a a matter
I wonder whether if she had been white
and working class whether she would have
had as much leeway to
do the terrible things that she did so
social class
ethnicity all kinds of things in which
she was particular and not necessarily
um
reflecting the diversity of nursing I
think that she she seems to have got
away with terrible conduct
because she had some privilege and I it
I don't think it's solely being white I
think more than anything had she been
white and working class I'm not sure she
would have got as much leeway to do the
terrible things that she did
uh you're echoing there some of the
comments um not I don't think
deliberately but that we've heard as
well from various uh people from nursing
associations as well let's just remind
ourselves what glamor magazine said
about this wouldn't normally sort of
cite this as a serious you know
reference nothing against glamor
magazine but this was a really really
strident article they put out Nadine as
Bali here perhaps an immigrant nurse
with subpar English and a foreign name
could be a fitting figure for those
Unthinkable murders we can imagine
impoverished murderers black murderers
Muslim murderers because that's a
narrative told To Us by every tabloid
paper going those people are capable of
violence but not an English Rose in
nurses scrubs do you think that language
their way she's framed it is
particularly provocative
it's I don't know about provocative I
mean it's that's journalism frankly
um
I think it's partly right
but I do think that her her social class
seems to have played I'm just thinking
about the minions or or the certainly
many
um working class white women who are not
privileged for notwithstanding that
they're they don't have the racism that
I and many others
experience but
I'm not sure that a white working class
nurse would have got away with that and
we're not talking about one or two
incidents we're talking about
a lot you I mean I want to bring Jenny
in in the studio Jenny Cleveland joins
us she's been listening uh they're
talking and you've had some reactions to
that it's an argument that's been put
out there as well and we're hearing
there from Jenny not just race but
social classes playing it to the reason
that these murders were overlooked the
reason these murders were overlooked was
because the hospital I mean there's
going to be an inquiry but what we know
from what the many white Consultants as
well as as people of color who reported
Lucy letby they all said that they
reported her and the managers at the
hospital were worried about the
reputation of the hospital and so they
didn't take action that is why she was
able to get away with these murders was
because the hospital was was trying to
cover up for itself was trying to
protect its own reputation and I think
that discussions like this are a bit of
a red herring really and it take the
focus away from what we need to do to
avoid things like this happening again I
think people are surprised when a woman
is a murderer because generally most
most murderers are not women and uh you
know people are surprised when someone
who is in a caring profession whose job
it is to look after uh babies is a
murderer it's it's really shocking but
the idea that she was allowed to get
away with this because of race is is a
red herring when we know she was allowed
to get away with it because the hospital
failed to take the necessary action to
protect those babies this argument being
and I don't say that I necessarily back
it though that the hospital ignored and
didn't take action because as we're
hearing from Jenny the argument that
sorry Linda are that the argument is
social class and or race depending which
article you're reading well I mean we'll
need to see what what the inquiry says
of why the hospital didn't take action
but if it was to do with race you have
to remember that it was a lot of white
people and also black and brown people
who who reported her so it seems to be
people from all sides were drawing
attention to the fact that she was on
duty when all these babies were were
dying class may very well be a factor
there's certainly a problem with racism
within the NHS nurses are black nurses
are more likely to face Fitness to
practice hearings than white nurses and
when there is a lot of evidence they are
more likely to be to be cleared so we
know that there is a kind of benefit of
the doubt that that white nurses and
white nurses who are of a different
social class will get but when it comes
to murder this is a different thing this
isn't about good nurses and bad nurses
this is about murderers being allowed to
get away with it and I think we know
that in this case she was allowed to get
away with it because the hospital was
worried about calling in the police and
potentially damaging their reputation if
they did let's go back to uh Linda
listening in there because this idea of
having the conversation at all I'm
listening to uh Jenny they say where
does it take us because it doesn't bring
the babies back that have been murdered
but does having discussion about this
idea of how things are overlooked
potentially stop similar crimes and
taking place the future is there any
case for reform here or is this all just
a red herring
uh it's not a red herring like the the
word that comes to my mind is equality
and that means that there ought to be
equal treatment for both patients the
babies who were born and the nurses the
doctors that being treated less
favorably or more favorably is a
reflection of inequality
so I I put that point to you but there's
things about there are things about the
treatment of of of people in hospital
where social class does
become a factor about who gets what
and in the case or in this case it's
that's not the same thing I mean what
what is happening what has happened is
less favorable treatment for babies
being murdered being okay yeah
uh and and
somebody got away with it up to I mean
there are these children will not come
back and some are damaged and are still
alive this is it's terrible I
I I continue to be shocked
I'm 72 years old I'm I've I've lived
most all of my life virtually in in
Britain I am shocked that this has
happened but I I don't know to what
extent any politics has played a role I
don't know but I am so shocked and
disgusted that this has happened that we
it's not just float you know blaming
people
are a person did this we are all shocked
we're all disgusted by this case look uh
thank you for joining us this evening to
give us your thoughts on that and thank
you also to Jenny cleeman joining us in
the studio as well once entered next
could artificial intelligence take the
place of novelists when it comes to who
writes our summer reads that's the
suggestible for AJ choudhary the great
Freddy full size says it's a crime
against penmanship they're going head to
head out for the break
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but it's making me cry again we're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
let it roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off shorts
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American ass thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about yeah
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
[Music]
now what book are you reading this
summer a Julie Cooper bunk Buster the
latest lead child maybe a Frederick
Forsyth classic we've got all our
favorite authors of course we all know
what we like soon though it could be AI
writing the books we take to the beach
crime author and Tech entrepreneur RJ
choudry has revealed he is using
artificial intelligence to help shape
his latest plot he says it will be the
norm for all authors in the near future
and he's here in the studio with us RJ
chaudry and from his home the
best-selling author journalist and
living legend of English letters the
aforementioned Frederick Forsyth joining
us as well to debate this topic
um his foresight I'll start with you if
you don't mind and ask you how you feel
about Artificial Intelligence being
involved in novel writing
I think it's a contract
um frankly I got no time for it I
believe that artificially children so
ever sophisticated
it may be is still if it's Century the
product of a machine
not the human brain
and if you're going to write a novel I
think it should be your novel meaning
stemming 100 from your brain that I
suspect is what the reader paying good
money over a counter would expect and
want and be surprised to be given the
product of a piece of basically
technology
okay thank you for those opening views
let's go to RJ in the studio who's
joined us who is using artificial
intelligence to write
you're hearing that I'm sure you're used
to hearing that type of thing now uh so
give us the case for why you would use
AI um look I'm a huge fan of Frederick
Forsyth um uh you know he inspired me to
write with his first book but the
reality is I don't think any novel is
the product of one person's brain you
have editors you have readers you have a
lot of people who provide input into it
and the way I use it I would never use
AI to write my book for me but I would
use it very much to bounce ideas off
just as I might of my editor I would
absolutely use it if I'm stuck and say
hey give me a few scenarios that I might
be able to go forward with and what I
found was for my last novel which has
just come out called the detective I was
actually researching the negative bits
of AI and that's what the book's about
but as I started researching it I
realized this could actually be really
useful and it actually cut the time of
writing and gave my editor a much more
polished draft now it'll be Never As
Good an editor as her because she knows
me she knows my style but it absolutely
helps um so I'm a huge fan okay you're a
huge fan I want to come back to
Frederick Forsyth on that point that RJ
just made about a book not being from
one person's brain being a sort of
collaborative project is there any
argument for that
I believe that obviously the Improvement
of the script uh the Polish uh what is
in in essence an editorial job that can
be left to a machine to insist but not
the creation
if the creation doesn't isn't from the
brain of the author it shouldn't be
under his or her name
otherwise it's not what I call authentic
and I think you have to stress that word
authentic is it authentic or is it
artificial a check and the meaning of
both words artificial can be created by
anything it can be well
um it's phony it can be a Conor
um whereas authentic is authentic and
there's only one meaning of that word
authentic it comes from where it's
supposed to come from or it's supposed
to come from on the cover of a book is
the author his ideas or hers and yes you
can polish it with a good editor
um and a bit of artwork and a nice cover
make it more attractive in many ways but
you can't or shouldn't in my view change
the plot to suit a machine well let's
have a look what a machine comes up with
and a plot we actually entered into chat
GPT which is an AI program a lot of our
viewers will be familiar with we asked
the machine write a preface for an
uncensored Espionage Thriller novel in
the by the Frederick foresight with
Piers Morgan as the main character this
was the story it came up with in the
murky abyss of information manipulation
and covert agendas one man stood
defiantly against the tide of deception
Piers Morgan a name whispered in all by
allies and intrepidation by enemies
navigated the treacherous currents of
Power with the Precision of a surgeon's
scalpel as Dawn's first light pierce the
London Fog Morgan's piercing gaze locked
onto a dossier promised to shatter the
shackles of half truths and manufactured
narratives and we even got the machine
to give us a cover for what this book
would be like this is what it would look
like uncensored Piers Morgan looking a
bit like Colin further which I think
he'll be terribly pleased with that
we'll chat with him later uh Frederick
what do you make of that plot
it may be very very fine plot I'm not
denying that the machine can't come up
with a plot just that you shouldn't pass
it off for someone else's that's all
so is the answer here just to have some
sort of labeling that says this is an AI
produced book so people can make that
choice
yeah yeah exactly authenticity it either
is or is not by Frederick Forsyth and if
it is not my friendship is like there's
parts of his life a friendships like the
parts of my Gizmo sitting in the corner
uh the John Rita should be told that so
that he can think no I think I'll buy
another book after all the Gizmo City in
the corner RJ you've been nodding along
uh in the studio to a lot of this the
authenticity point that Frederick's
pointy up but also the labeling so let's
let's talk about the authenticity Point
can an AI assisted book really be
considered authentic
um look I I don't think AI writes very
well um you saw that piece I mean
Frederick writes a lot better than that
does however this point about it should
be by the authors is an interesting one
because a lot of writers like Agatha
Christie Wilbur Smith Robert Ludlum uh
stey glass and they've all died but
they've still been publishing books
after they're dead because they've been
written by other people now people
aren't buying these books because they
know the person who wrote it necessarily
they're buying it because it's a puero
book Steve Larsen book etc etc and I
could see a future I'm not very pleased
about that future where an Agatha
Christie or a puero could be written by
AI it would have to be a lot better than
this and I think people might still buy
it I completely agree it should be
labeled so it should be you know Poirot
etc etc etc written by chat GPT
um and I would imagine that would come
but this point about editing polishing I
think in a year's time people would be
amazed we were having this conversation
it would be like using a grammar checker
or a spell checker uh the way you do
right you're not concerned it's going to
put writers out of a job full stop not
at all because one thing AI cannot do is
create empathy it cannot create lovable
characters real characters you know the
reason I love Dave The Jackal was
because you read that character and
thought this is an incredible character
there's absolutely no way an AI could
ever do that when people read my books
they read them because they like the
characters they like the arcs the AI
could come up with a plot and indeed
occasionally if I'm stuck I'll go to the
AI and ask it for ideas and I might use
some of those ideas but it'll never
actually create a great character in my
view coming back to you uh Frederick
listening in on that as well
this idea of uh publishing and music and
creation and performance being able to
be done once somebody has passed away as
well as RJ just bought up there we're
hearing this about musicians as well
it's a big concern in Hollywood uh how
would you feel about books going out
with Frederick Forsyth name um 50 to 100
years from now
well again I think it's of course of
attribution
and that word is very very to me very
very important if the fellow dead fine
say okay this is after so so this is
after so and so there are books being
out being brought out with James Bond
novels I think there are now four or
five different authors being contracted
to write quote James Bond novels uh but
they're clearly not by the original
creator of James Bond but so long as
that's made plain I don't think there's
any trickery involved uh what I worry
about is that it may not be made plain
that some of this comes a machine a
clever machine but nevertheless a
machine machines obviously don't
um sit at expensive restaurant tables
and eat lots and lots of expensive food
they don't have to be paid royalties how
very very convenient you don't have to
take a gizmo in the corner out for a
nice lunch at the publisher do you ready
lit
let's talk about some of the the legal
ramifications about this as well because
this week a federal judge in the U.S
made the Judgment the AI art cannot be
copyrighted it's going to have a massive
impact in the future of AI Arts uh do
you think that's at least the reasonable
protection I I think it is um I'm not a
lawyer so I can comment on it they've
said essentially needs to have a certain
amount of human input they haven't
defined what certain amount of human
input is I do find it slightly odd
because they said a machine cannot you
cannot copyright something created by
machine but I can take my iPhone and
take a photograph of this lovely studio
and it would be my copyright and that's
all I've done I've just taken a
photograph of it but if I go to AI I put
in a prompt I then take the image I
manipulate the image and produce
Something Beautiful the fact that I
can't copyright that whereas I could
with the photograph seems slightly odd
to me and an AI photograph actually won
the top prize in the Sony Awards uh they
didn't know it was an AI photograph they
gave it the award and then the the
photographer fessed up and said this was
Ai and then they pulled the award so
clearly it was good enough quality to
win the award because they gave it to it
I still find it all slightly deeply
worrying and I wish it would stop but I
appreciate the conversation anyway RJ
chaudry best of luck with your novel
Frederick Forsyth thank you so much for
joining us from home this evening as
well thank you
uncensored next and I prince Andrew
joins the king in Balmoral as Charles
axes peace talks with Harry as they only
wrote back for the Royal Renegades
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk Rishi sunak admits
defeat on his battle to stock small
boats Lucy let these former boss
threatens legal action over claims she
ignored warnings about the killer nurse
and is the Royal Rift about to be
repaired sources say peace talks are
being arranged for King Charles and
Prince Harry that's all coming up at
nine
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now King
Charles and queen Camilla have started
their summer holidays this week like
much the rest of you apart from Lego to
the traditional bowel barrel of course
I've been Scotland joining them over the
weekend for a summer in the highlands in
what many see is something of an olive
branch was disgraced to a younger
brother to the king prince Andrew
not being offered an olive branch is
Prince Harry who hasn't received the
invite to peace talks many were
expecting to take place next month so
what does this all mean for the Renegade
Royals joining me to discuss all of this
joined by the author and historian Tessa
Dunlop the host of die for daily podcast
Kenzie Schofield and commentator Hillary
fordwick thank you all three of you for
joining us uh for this discussion it
feels like a test is in the studio with
me Tessa it feels like a while since we
have done royals here on Piers Morgan
and so I've been the chair for a couple
of weeks now and there was a period of
course all through the year where there
were so many Royal events and so much to
talk about have you found it a bit
quieter a bit and then um a certain
individual didn't turn up down under and
there was a little storm in a teacup and
your Alter Ego appears I noticed as
disconcolate and he actually tweeted you
know he should be on the plane mate or
hrh or however he referred to him and I
thought peers have you spent so long
hammering away at Harry and Andrew that
you've forgotten that no one is a saint
not even the king and the next in line
to the throne and yes it was a chance
for William to broaden his base and I'm
afraid he scored a bit of an own goal
but Piers isn't here to defend himself
but he did certainly tweak that you
brought up Andrew there now prince
Andrew this is what we've advised him to
talk about he is this it coming in for
the cold what do you read into it well
and Kinsey will be hot off the calls
because she's uh Stateside where they've
just released
um this big tell-all or tell more
documentary on Andrew including
interviews with Emily maitless who of
course uh delivered that was meant to be
a sort of courtroom style interview in
Buckingham Palace which Hook Line and
sync it Andrew but certainly there is
more coming out I think the wish was
from the prince that he could coolly
hand over was it about 12 million I
think there's some undisclosed including
some money apparently from the late
Queen and it would all go away no such
luck Andrew and you might be up in
Balmoral right now or heading up there
but that doesn't mean people aren't
talking about you let's go over to
Kenzie then you brought her up Kenzie
joins us thanks so much from Stateside
uh time to bring prince Andrew in what
do you read into it
I I think he's still a liability to the
royal family perhaps more so than Prince
Harry and Meghan Markle uh you know it
was the Queen's wish that they could
stop the bleeding when it came to this
story and look at us today we've got
hours and hours of additional interviews
and people dissecting the Jeffrey
Epstein Scandal I don't think I know
time heals all wounds but we need more
time when it comes to prince Andrew I
think that
um you know I just think that this was
such a destructive uh destructive
incident and I do fear that it could be
his legacy destructive and
internationally renowned of course Let's
cross over to uh Hillary as well and
talk about the Prince Harry element in
this because uh Tessa began by saying
it's sort of almost like an own goal
being scored you know we've had Harry
heading over to Singapore he's playing
in a pilot match he got criticism for
that uh he's now I believe back in
Montecito but this idea that he was
going to print peace talks with King
Charles and that's now off the agenda do
you think we are going to see any sort
of reconciliation
well pleasure to be back with you again
and good afternoon Stateside as you
mentioned evening there but a few things
the biggest news actually with regard to
Harry is something that the mainstream
media and I don't know whether it's just
that it's not quite public yet the
biggest news is with regard to Edward
Long Edward long was referred to in
Prince Harry's um sort of damn all
autobiography throwing the royal family
under the proverbial bus he was referred
to as the bee he is one of the courtiers
he was very loyal for many years to the
queen our late beloved Queen now King
Charles has honored him he now will be
Lord young and he now will be taking on
Royal events for the king in his absence
so in abstentia he will be made in the
position of the king what does this mean
this literally is taking sides it's
saying who matters it's saying who has
been dedicated to duty and it is not at
all obviously what Prince Harry would
ever have wanted so I think now you can
see definitely where the lines are being
drawn now the king of course has a big
heart obviously most fathers would love
to reconcile with their son but I think
this is a huge move we're seeing with
regard to Lord Young
I I think you make an interesting point
Hillary but in perhaps some ways you put
20 together and you make five Harry is
not a working member of the royal family
the likelihood of him rubbing up against
um Lord long in the near future or the
distant future is pretty minimal and
actually what needs repaired within the
royal family are those personal
relations between William Charles and
Harry and I think we've spent too long
as a media and I include all of us
lobbing uh
criticism back at the sussexes ah Andrew
these guys really they're pretty
irrelevant when it comes to the state
institution that is the monarchy how do
we go forward and future proof that
monarchy that I think all of us here
believe in
um and make sure that things like mexit
as people uh refer to it or the prince
Andrew debacle that keeps on bleeding as
Kinsey put it don't happen again and
that I believe requires written Branch
reform that we could push for in the
press that we could properly get down
and dirty and look at what's working for
that state institution monarchy and what
isn't but instead we're going for this
soap opera side show oh look what
Charles has appointed he's appointed a
man that Harry won't like and it's
actually I don't think helpful for
anyone let's bring in Kenzie's Lord go
on go on Hillary I'll give you a chance
to respond go on yes Lord young not long
um I think it's very important to see
the continuity I think it's very
important to see what does matter I
think this is a great move in terms of
what does matter and of course Prince
Harry isn't working anymore as a senior
role due to his own decision yes uh
Kinsey want to bring you back in on this
and ask about the other gentleman
involved in probably a lot of these
proposed peace talks and decisions
Prince William the brother of Prince
Harry uh quote uh feels utterly betrayed
by what Harry wrote about him in his
book spare and said about him on Netflix
they were very close growing up it's
been very painful for him of course do
you think he is having an outsized role
in this uh proposed reconciliation
well that's certainly what The Daily
Beast is reporting The Daily Beast is
reporting that he is the one that
stepped in and said that absolutely not
they were not going to have peace talks
with Prince Harry that you know that
incident that happened right after
Prince Philip's funeral that private
moment where Prince William was begging
him to please listen to him and his
father ends up in you know the first
chapter of spare that's a complete
violation of their privacy and you know
that I do believe that Prince William
would likely
prefer to keep a distance from Prince
Harry at this point in time the Sussex
brand is toxic and I don't think he
trusts them
let's go on Tessa well I I hear that and
I totally understand between siblings it
can get really personal but what you
have with the institution of monarchy is
it's a state gas and through those fault
lines runs the family and sometimes
William has to be encouraged to sit back
to take a bigger View and think what
looks best for monarchy what's actually
going to work in terms of the monarchy
going forward his father is defender of
the faith he's meant to be a leading
Christian that's meant to be about
forgiveness about reconciliation and I
would like to see that from our monarchy
please Kenzie but do you not feel like
it makes the entire monarchy look weak
to take absolute kicks in the teeth
between Netflix between spare and then
say no come on back we'll take some more
you know not knowing confidently that
things that they say in their presence
might not end up spoken out loud to
Oprah Winfrey on live television or end
up in a podcast in the future I think
they're protecting their brand think
they're protecting their sanity and
their mental health because you know I I
can't imagine what it's like to say
things out loud and to have those
Secrets whispered on International
television or in a podcast or book or
Netflix series I think that they're
trying to protect their future by
distancing themselves are actually also
doing the right thing which is
dedication dedication to duty that's
what they're doing they're keeping calm
they're carrying on and they're doing
what the British public and members of
the Commonwealth and everyone actually
seems to admire decent people dislike
dishonesty and they respect and admire
Duty and you actually saw that also with
recent polls with regard to Prince
William of course in the U.S he was
ranked even higher than President Biden
and the king and that's mainly a lot due
to his dedication to duty and and
Hillary we hear a great deal from those
who really support the monarchy they
have a loud voice they have a live voice
and establishment media and rightly so
they're proud of that institution we
don't hear from the 25 of britons who
actively want want to see the end of
monarchy I don't think by the way
William helped his cause when he didn't
think oh I'm gonna sit on a plane for 22
hours it is a pain in the neck but I'm
going to do it because people like the
14 year old kid that's going to be
walking alongside my son's reign will
buy into that and see that I gave up
some of my holiday and did it and
actually what I think we need to be
honest about is that the monarchy is
operating from a position of strength so
Kinsey referred to it wouldn't they look
weak but they have so much that they're
well I think actually establishment they
can afford to give a bit they they are
the ones that can give forward and step
forward with the Olive Branch with
regard to that 25 I always think it's
rather interesting though whenever the
next question is asked and you are right
there is a movement in the Hillary we're
gonna have to wrap it up there
unfortunately we have run out of time uh
sorry to cut you off there because uh we
did want to hear the rest of it but
Straight Out of Time Hillary uh Tessa
Kinsey thanks so much that is it from us
whatever you're up to tonight make sure
it is uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean
you believe you can win this war it's
making me cry again I'm trying to force
you out yes I feel betrayed keep it
award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through
in some way is an excuse
for at what
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election can we yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]